[Music]  you are a very sharp dresser and I've  been noticing at these award shows you  are always dressed obviously very well  some people your age some guys don't  like to dress up you know they don't  like to put on a suit they think it  makes them uncomfortable do you like it  are you okay with it yeah it makes me  feel like the secret agent James Bond I  also love going on red carpets and doing  very cool poses like this is one it's  called blue steel which camera wow look  at that run right there or the red  lights tree yeah give me your blue steel  [Applause]  get two more yeah let's see them what's  the next one I'm working on both of  these are not done yet  this one is community and bacon Canadian  bacon there are very subtle differences  here this is a different one okay this  one's different  well this okay it's different okay  that's one third one's different  it's called maple syrup maple syrup here  we go  [Applause]